the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
um thank you all for uploading all your
stuff last night we do watch everything
just you know and its really really
helpful for us so I really appreciate
you guys doing that I thought we'd start
off today by doing just a quick exercise
where you say the point of your video
and one to two sentences and I was
thinking about this last night because
it's actually a really nuanced thing
understanding the difference between
what the point of your video is and what
your video does I was trying to think of
a good way to explain it last night in
this morning and I think that might be
the best way for me to understand it and
that's why I gave that example of the
snot video right because the point of
the video that i made about snot wasn't
to explain what's not is that's what my
video does but the point of it is to
show that this material that you take
for granted that's in your body actually
does all these XYZ amazing things so
does the difference between those two
things make sense to you guys or do you
recognize the difference between those
two things so for instance someone at
Joshua your video may be about what
binary searches right but that's not the
point of your video that's what your
video does in achieving the point of
your video explaining what binary search
is is sort of a happy afterthought right
but it's not what drives the video
forward so if we could just go around
and pitch the point of your video and
one did you sent one to two sentences
and the more specific it is the better
right because we can generalize things
like the point of my video is to explain
how amazing snot is but that's actually
not that different from the point of my
video is to explain what's not as right
I've just thrown in an attitude
basically
so does that sound okay to everyone
and I think this will be helpful because
once you really think of what the thesis
of your video is it's going to help you
a lot and scripting because you'll
always be able to go back to that big
point right if your scripting with the
objective of explaining what what a
fractal is that's what yulia's video is
about it's really easy to get lost in
the details right so that's that's the
whole point of this exercise does
anybody want to go first otherwise we'll
just go in order okay awesome thanks
Josh so you just had anything that my
video was about how how to how do we
sorry it was about the binary search
algorithm but i guess the team here is
why can i find my stuff and how can i
find that there that's what the team is
about and the question is can can google
teach me how to do my own search you
might like better I think that's a
really good start right because we were
talking about yesterday or the power of
questions but again the point of your
video isn't the question the point of
your video is the answer to the question
so what if you go from there and try to
go for two sentences that try to answer
those questions
do for example and well wait say the
questions again why kind of find my
stuff how can i find it bear okay so
Josh how can you find your stuff better
if we keep a list of like where is it
located or better yet if they're
positioned in a way that has a
relationship among them so so it's kind
of like if you put your stuff in the
toilet you know everything you need to
use in at all and you put them in that
location and so you avoid putting things
in pressure square they don't they don't
need to be there but you please any
things where the relationship is natural
so basically what you're saying is that
the way you organize objects isn't just
for aesthetic purposes it can actually
change the time and efficiency in which
you find things which doesn't sound like
a big deal until you realize that that's
the fundamental way that something is
huge as Google uses is that correct yes
does that feel like more of a point then
this is how our search engine works as
more of a point
something worthy of writing down as a
ravine like from Uli's maybe I'm a
visual person but like that's a reason
thats a really important positive we
just figured out right it's like it's a
super nuanced thing and very difficult
to figure out it's a lot easier to
figure out someone else's point than
your own actually which is why I wanted
you guys to come up with a script
sometime tomorrow it's a lot easier for
me at least as an editor to give
productive feedback when I actually had
like something tangible in front of me
so your questions were really great
starting point and the script that you
wrote is also a really great starting
point because there's a lot of material
to work with but I wouldn't have been
able to figure out that that was your
point unless I had had those materials
right the questions are a super good
starting point oftentimes the point of
your video is going to be the answer to
those questions right so the questions
set up the video but the point of the
video is not the questions it's like the
difference between a symptom
disease from a doctor's perspective
phrase if that's a different way of
thinking about it if you keep asking
like why is something inching we're in
the finishing and you finally
understanding for reason to why that's
that things where you're trying to get
this yeah and I think it's a very
compelling way to set up not just video
but scientific papers talks anytime
you're trying to sell an idea to someone
grant proposals oftentimes you'll ask
somebody you know I'm going or you're
going to this conference what are you
going to do and their answers well I'm
going to talk about the research that I
did right and like that's not really
helpful obviously you're going to talk
about the research you did what I want
to know is what is your research I know
that you're going to talk about binary
search probably from the title of your
video what I want to know is what is it
right so let's do this one more time can
you describe the point of your video
into sentences or less
the way we could find things better is
the way we could
think of wondering
that's a good start that's good right so
the way we can find them is better
you're trying to relate a concept or an
everyday experience that we had like
organizing things so the way we organize
things yeah the way we findings better
is the way Google to find out our
results better yeah that's a much
stronger point than the questions you
had initially and and saying the point
is to exploit binary searches right and
you can flush that out a little bit more
but DC where where we're going with this
yuliya were going around doing one to
two-sentence explanations of what our
videos are do you want to let's have
other people go since you just got here
Paul do you mind going next so mimes
about using principles that kids already
familiar with like floating and sinking
to show an application of naval
architecture specifically how to prevent
ships from sinking using subdivision and
our camisa
so that is very informative that's like
a perfect description of what your video
is going to be that may be verbatim what
you put as the summary in the YouTube
video right like it that's going to be
super helpful to a teacher who's like
looking through the videos and wanting
to find out what the videos are about so
I guess my question would be what are
the actual principles that kids learn
that would help them understand so
kids are familiar with floating and
sinking
the second ring or something like that
and not just kids with everyone yeah so
you could start off most people are
familiar with the concepts of floating
and sinking right how you can get looks
that I like divide your ship so that
float when it's damaged
no no that's that's a great start and
oftentimes what I I personally like a
lot and maybe this is something that
we've been repeating over and over again
but the whole concept of the unexpected
the familiar becoming unfamiliar as
Chris was talking about the the fact
that a huge piece of technical equipment
like a ship can be protected from
sinking with using just the basic
principles that even second graders know
is actually really amazing all right so
maybe that's something that you can sort
of play off of in the point of your
video that the concepts that we learn as
children like why things float and why
things sink are actually the building
blocks of of knowing how to protect
machinery like submarines from sinking
even when they get damaged you know and
like the wording of that obviously isn't
super great but like yeah an aircraft
carrier which is one of those sort of
complicated machines ever built is based
on the fact that it can even float is
based on this very simple yeah you know
yeah I think like yeah I think that's
like a very strong point to the video
actually I love I personally love the
idea of compare complexity from
simplicity that the things that people
often think of as being really
complicated like naval architecture or
systems biology are actually built off
of really simple concepts and really
simple ideas does that make sense to
people okay David how will i see you
next the point of my video is some
people are naturally predisposed to
better survive the next ice age sorry I
didn't hear some people are better
disposed to what some people are better
predisposed to better survive the next
ice age yeah and they could be
predisposed by genetically or physically
or maybe they just do meditation yeah
actually that that is a point right
that's like that's a thesis that's an
argument and I think that's a very
interesting one but notice that it
wasn't the pitch wasn't why are some
people more predisposed to this or why
do I feel cold but my friend doesn't
write the pit or the point is an answer
to those questions does anyone have
feedback or suggestions on maybe ways
that David could alter the point at all
I think and again no one is ever going
to read your point right no one is ever
going to see your thesis written out
before they watch your video the idea is
that they're going to watch the video
and they're going to come to the same
conclusion that you've written so it's
okay if like the wordings not perfect
because no one's ever going to read it
they're just gonna watch your video but
I guess if you're going to publish it I
would open up with things like genetic
makeup or you know physiological
differences among people are what might
predispose certain humans to survive the
next ice age Kenneth you want to go next
the most sucks in point and figure out
this letting them know that time travel
right now it's not doable yet yeah it's
the most sucks in point I can dig up
chain if one elaborate a bit morn that
our it's to let you know that we can
possibly travel forward in time pasta
but traveling back in time requires too
much energy um again nice distilled
point i guess my question would i would
say that you could flush that out a
little bit more for the point because
that's like time travel is not possible
is the ultimate argument that you're
making with like a super broad one so
you can include maybe why it's not
possible again because it takes too much
energy i don't exactly know what that
means that maybe your video is going to
cover that okay and
Andrea do you feel comfortable going
sure that's okay but see when you throw
that out there it it makes it a lot
easier for us to give feedback right it
gives us something to work off of the
video illustrates how engineers and
medicine use natural processes in our
bodies to actually improve a repair
warranty so I actually think the point
is in there if you just take out the
first three words engineers and what was
it scientists use natural processes in
our bodies to what
yeah I actually think the point is in
there if you just get rid of the my
video explains which is kind of awesome
considering where she started to indo
yeah right like the braces like you've
totally done the off with all them yeah
yeah yeah negative them way to go Nathan
you want to go we are the only ones who
you director and like without them would
be a lot
that's pretty good I was pretty good at
Nathan had an aha moment last night if
you heard his reflection and I'm really
excited to see where you go with that
but very very different point and
answered to my question than the one you
gave like yesterday so I asked him what
the point of his videos was yesterday
and he was like to explain what
decomposition is but do you see how this
is like a completely different point and
a much more engaging one and in
explaining and getting to that point he
is going to cover what decomposition is
right all right Julia
repeating patterns called fractals are
present in every facet of our existence
and are indispensable in nature research
medicine and technology in that way
mathematics helps us explore and
understand the world around us nice
any feedback
can you eat it yeah repeating fractals
repeating patterns called fractals are
present in every facet of our existence
and our indispensable in nature research
medicine and technology in that way Matt
helps us explore it understand the world
around us that's also a super different
point than the one you're given
yesterday right yesterday the point of
your video was it wasn't even like what
is a fractal it was like what is the
philosophy of math right so those two
days ago yeah so hopefully with these
points it's going to help you script it
a tighter set of texts